Do you guys have those like
the Ring cameras in your house or the front--
No.
You don't?
No, I don't like what it does to the pupils.
Now what, what, what?
The pupil's wearing a fluorescent donut.
What are you talking about?
Now what?
Oh, you're talking about the Ring camera.
I was talking about the ring light.
Oh no, the ring light!
No wonder that was confusing.
Sorry.
The ring, like Instagrammer light around there?
Yes, I thought that's what you were talking about.
Yeah, you can't wear glasses on those.
No, I'm talking about those camera doorbells,
you know what I'm saying?
Oh.
Yes.
Okay, nevermind.
No worries.
(Drew laughing)
Well, this is about those doorbells and I love mine.
Because if there's any motion on the front porch,
I'm like, "Hello, hello,
leave it for me," you know the--
Like "Ferris Bueller's Day Off"?
Yeah, Bueller, Bueller.
The best.
But when they bring like a delivery or something,
I can say, "Just hide it behind the plant, thanks so much."
Well, one couple wants to kiss their Ring
after this story.
Oh.
The blog Simplemost reports that Sarah and Jeremy Henson,
from Kansas, were on a trip to Vegas
when their doorbell app buzzed on their phone,
it said there was motion at the front porch.
So they took a look and guess what they saw,
it was their dog, Dexter, was scratching at the front door
back in Kansas, they're in Vegas.
The dog was supposed to be at doggy daycare.
So they called the kennel and said that our dog's there.
And then did this thing,
they talked to their dog Dexter through the camera
until help could arrive and scoop him back up.
Look at this.
Good boy, here comes some lights.
Good boy, that's them, good boy.
Good boy.
Stay there, buddy.
Dexter was at the kennel, which was like two miles away,
somehow escaped and made it all the way
back to their house to their front porch.
Aw!
Right?
Okay, this is so crazy.
I needed to hear this story.
Yeah.
How do these animals do it?
It's so incredible!
I know, he's like, "I'm lost.
But I'm at the doorbell, ding dong, I'm right here."
I mean, animals are just,
they're incredible.
Wow.
And if you ever are wondering,
they're paying attention, they know you.
And like that whole loyalty thing,
I think it goes a lot deeper than we think.
(upbeat music)